this bracket and I'll get a better the
microphone yeah almost 300 million of
these were sold in 2021. and airpods are
by far the most popular they made up
about a third of all earbuds shipped
around the world last year but unlike an
iPhone or a Mac if one of these starts
to have an issue Apple might replace it
but it won't repair them or help you do
it yourself why is that to find out
we're going to take a look inside an
airpod and as technicians how repairable
they actually are yeah so tell me a
little bit about what you do at I fixed
it our job at iFixit is to assess the
repairability of electronic and consumer
devices anything that comes across our
teardown table we break apart to see how
repairable it is how hard is it to get
into these things if you want to take
the support non-destructively to replace
the batteries as far as I know that's
impossible so we're starting by melting
the glue I'm using this to melt the glue
yep God this feels so wrong oh it's
separating there you go
yeah let's take a break here okay one of
the reasons they use glue is because yes
it's a very effective way of preventing
sweat and moisture from getting inside
the question is is it worth the cost
we can replace the battery now
your airpod's not gonna work anymore but
you could replace the battery okay so
there you go build it boom nice all
right I think our best bet is just to
use the Sonic knife and go right through
okay that definitely went through okay
oh okay we got it do you think Apple
could put this thing together they won't
service these things I would love to be
proven wrong I would love for Apple to
say actually yeah we can get into these
and fix these so what exactly happens to
airpods after they have issues well
Apple says it will replace your airpod
and send the previous one to a
best-in-class recycler for responsible
handling Apple doesn't provide repair
manuals for air pods the way it does for
some iPhones and Macs that makes it that
much more difficult for third-party
technicians to make repairs and like we
saw earlier since these are so difficult
to get into repairing them probably
isn't the most practical option when it
comes to repairability iFixit rated the
original airpods Pro a definitive 0 out
of 10. and since it's one of the most
unrepairable among its competitors so
why does that matter well Apple shift
more than 90 million earbuds in 2022
alone within a couple of years a lot of
those airpods will end up being recycled
or tossed in the trash because of this
part right here experts say the
batteries used in Bluetooth earbuds only
last about 18 months before they start
to have problems let's take a look at
this graph I'll not focus specifically
on air pods It generally shows how
Lithium-ion batteries age the x-axis
shows how many times the battery is
cycled or charged and discharged the
y-axis shows how much the battery can
store compared to its initial Max notice
that around 350 Cycles things really
drop off the lead researcher told me
that drop in the graph is the reason
your device can work fine one day and
have performance issues and less battery
life than next apple acknowledges that
rechargeable batteries have a limited
lifespan it says how long they last
depends on how often you charge them
eventually performance issues might send
you back to the Apple Store for a new
pair or those old earbuds may end up in
a drawer the garage or the
recycling bin so can airpods be repaired
yes if you want you can try at home
although I don't recommend it's so
tedious it may be hard but that doesn't
mean it's impossible swap club will send
you a refurbished pair of air pods and
try to repair your old ones the startup
developed a semi-automated way to fix a
variety of airpod issues if you do it
yourself it's probably going to take you
an hour and and the automation allows us
to to Really scale this according to
swap club there's just one small problem
in terms of repairability we see them
just getting Tighter and Tighter and we
have to continue to change our process
to accommodate that with each generation
there's a ton of tech packed into this
tiny thing and apple adds more each year
the new H2 chip adds longer battery life
there is also a new skin detection
sensor and it has a new swipe interface
and improved microphones for clearer
calls in the same generation we've
noticed some airpods have slight
differences the thing that we all love
the most about airpods which is their
tights small compact design is the thing
that actually makes it most difficult
for them to be repaired apple is working
within some guard rails it can only
increase the size so much if you want
earbuds that fit snugly in your ears and
apple doesn't want to make products that
are too complicated or look too
difficult to use so it's not just the
manufacturers we can't just blame the
manufacturers for creating the device
consumers are driving the demand for it
so after about two hours of work I only
managed to tear down one airpod and
obviously that thing's never going to
work again to be clear repairability
isn't just an apple issue all
rechargeable batteries will die
eventually and it's a pretty common
practice to hold things together with
glue but the thing is not all are as
hard to repair